please be patient as we begin our live
stream that will take a couple of
moments
all right very good welcome to our learn
it live session
applying machine learning to predict
consumer spending
um with sunil narsangani uh the author
of abc of machine learning this is going
to be a fascinating
session
and
first my name is stuart creek i'm a
marketing manager at simply learn i'm
going to
share with you the
instructions for using the webex
controls if you're not familiar please
do put all your questions for sunil into
the q a box
we will cue those up and we will
get to those at the end of his
presentation
you can put chat in if you want to
address it to
sunil or myself put all panelists and
with that i will start our first poll
we'll do one at the beginning and one at
the end of the session
and our poll
beginning is about you
and
just to give sunil a feel for the
audience uh please tell us how much work
experience you have
um
and
we have a second question on the poll
we're checking in with people how
they're doing today especially with the
new
news of the omicron variant
we are all
getting
strange and stressful messages
during the pandemic so we like to check
in with people and see how they're doing
and
just get your answers in and i will
share the poll results now
and we have a
bimodal distribution
sunil we have
a
number of people who have more than 10
years of experience
and we have a number of people who are
still in school
and
a smattering of people in between so
you have an interesting audience to
speak to today
and i will
close the poll
and introduce you
sunil narsengani is the author of the
abc of machine learning technology and
business visionary he's been in the
field for 20 years
specializing in machine learning and
data science and
the application of that to interesting
problems
he's worked with windwire technologies
mindtree mu sigma oracle india
uh and holds his master's degree in
industrial engineering and management
from iit kharagpur
um
car
sorry
so sunil
we are very pleased to have you here
today and welcome
uh
you're on mutants and elsa i'm gonna
unmute you here you go
can you hear me samia yes i can hear you
okay
yeah i can hear you now
okay is my screen visible
i am going to give you the sharing
privilege so you can do that
why don't you tell us just a a a little
bit more about yourself
and
how we came to this
problem today and then um
we'll get into your presentation
okay
i'm sunil
[Music]
always in search of some new application
of machine learning or some new
algorithm of machine learning
i was always
very much interested in
ordinarily square and regression but i
was always interested like there are so
many types of regression
what best we can do with them in machine
learning and data science
and then i found
this new algorithm this is not
this is something inbuilt in both our
python and other uh
other libraries but
uh not much use not much talked about so
i got very fascinated to know about it
and after knowing about it i was very
keen to use it somewhere
so couple of places where i
tried using it is was one was of course
customer credit card spending
other place i tried to use it was a
blood pressure of human bodies how they
can be pretty how it can be predicted
better
using quantum regression
so content regression was
something came up very fantastically
well and i jumped on this
great so why don't you go ahead and
share your screen now i think you have
the ability
not seeing your presentation yet
okay
okay can you hear me
uh i can hear you yeah you probably want
to turn your uh video off
and share your screen
okay so in this presentation we have
certain objectives we'll talk about that
then we will talk about quantile
regression what it is
so neil i'm still not saying
i'm still not seeing your presentation
on your screen can you
make sure you're sharing it
if not i will share it from this side
okay is it visible now
no it is
not let me share the slides from this
side
okay let me
last time this one says
is it visible now
yes yes it is
all right
i apologize to everyone for the
technical difficulties i
can tell you it went perfectly smoothly
in rehearsal
but
this is the nature of live television so
with that i'm going to
turn off my mic and let you go take over
sunu
hi
so we'll talk about what is quantile
regression is all about
then we'll talk about the random forest
then
with these two techniques quantum
regression and random forest comes the
quantile regression forest and we'll
talk about that
then we'll take about the credit card
sprint prediction
here this is just more like an example
and not a case study
we have simulated some data and tried
using it for our
demonstration so we'll show you some
input data
then we'll show you what output comes
out of the contact regression forest
so
after this presentation which will last
for around 60 minutes including 10
minutes of q a
uh we'll learn quantum regression forest
and its implementation to credit card
spending
or credit card expenditures
or to predict credit card expenditures
so first foremost thing is quantile
regression
so as i said first we all know about
linear regression predicts the
conditional mean and the point
prediction
so suppose i want you to predict a
credit card spread of some user you will
definitely predict something like 750
dollars but that 750 is just a mean
mean of mean or a point prediction
but what quantum prediction quantile
regression predicts is it predicts the
conditional quantile
conditional content means i will tell
you the median of the expenditure will
be 740 dollars but it will move between
700 and 800 dollars so i am going to
give you a range prediction and that is
the best definition of point type
regression is it gives us a range
prediction
range on the basis of quantiles
we all know qantas very well
we must have heard about percentile we
must have heard about a quartile all
these are example of quantile statistics
of some some data
so quantum regression predicts a range
based on the point types
uh content output is a range
it might be more useful example as i i
told you a credit card person may spend
1100 to 1500.
now
1200 is very fine number for this but it
may definitely go wrong there is some
uncertainty comes up
100 to 1500 range when we talk about
range lot of
uncertainty get covered out of that
it hides the uncertainty
and the
lower the range
smaller the range
more confident we could be how much will
be the spend and that gives us lot of
lot of advantage
and uh
we can say that 90 of chances are there
that 11 the spend between will be
between 1100 and 1500 and that gives lot
of advantage how i will come to that but
remember if this range goes bigger
bigger bigger that also happens our
advantage will be diminished we will in
less advantageous position if we
if this range is very big and we don't
want that we want this range to be
predicted and it should be as small as
possible with certain degree of
percentage 10 percentile and 90
percentile
values will should be very near to each
other and that is what quantile
regression gives us
you must have heard about term homo
sadasticity
that linear regression is having a
compulsion that data or it's having
assumption or very strong assumption
that data is having homosexy that means
if if you have y is equal to mx plus c
plus epsilon epsilon is the error we
have not measured
epsilon always follows a normal
distribution
this is
a normal distribution and the variance
will always be same and this is called
homocydasticity
so pointed regression is contrary to
this quantum regulation is good in case
of heterostatisticity as well
this restriction is not there on quantum
regression and that is another very big
positive point how it is a good positive
point i'll come to that in my subsequent
slides
quantity regression can be solved by a
method very similar to ordinary least
square method
but
it can also be solved by random forest
and random forest solves it better
that's why we created our presentation
by solving it using random forest method
so we will solve this regression problem
with the random forest
now what about a random forest
random forest is made up of two words
random and forest
random
stands for
the randomization we do when we pick up
the data and create a random forest so
in each each decision tree and each
split
we choose a certain rows
at random that is a sample
and
we also choose
uh certain columns not all variables
participate in creation of tree but
certain variables at selected at random
participate in
creation of the tree and that is why
this is called random forest
forest stands for large number of trees
so i i here i am assuming that all our
audience is familiar with the tree
method or tree technique
decision trees
battery i mean decision trees so large
number of decision trees are created in
the random forest that is why the word
forest comes out because forest means
lot of trees
solving classification
random forest solves both classification
and regression problem
it calculates mean value of the target
variable for each leaf tree when we use
it for regression
but
it can be used differently as well as we
use it in the
quantile regression forest so most of
the technique is same
but
and hundreds of trees have been used but
they are used differently when we solve
a content regression problem from the
random forest
now giving you better insight of random
first is suppose you see this picture on
the right side there is a big circle on
the left of it that is the whole
population
then what we do is we do bagging
bagging stands for bootstrap aggregation
and in the bootstrapping we take out
small small small samples which are
represented by small smaller circles on
the right side
once we say
and on each
each booster
each
boosted sample we create one tree
that is created as a tree icon here and
once we create large number of trees we
combine the result of all the trees and
create a consolidated result and that is
called aggregation so
random forest is a method of bootstrap
aggregation and
there are four parts to it one is a big
population sample there are sub sampling
there is decision trees and there is
aggregation
random forest is
mostly used or predominantly used in
sampling technique in machine learning
i mean in sampling is large number of
models are created
to create a consolidated model and a
consolidated prediction
which is always better than the
individual which is called a weak
learner model prediction
and random forest is a prominent method
of ensembling
and
in machine learning it is used
predominantly
random forest also do one very basic
thing that is bias and variance trade
off
bias and variance are two constituents
of error
random forest tries to minimize the
total error by reducing the variance and
white bias also get decreased in the
real world hypothetically it increased
little of bias but it reduced subsequent
substantially large amount of variance
and with that said it does varies
bias variance trade-off and reduce the
total error so with the as it reduce the
total error random forest predictions
are
a lot more accurate than other methods
which which may not be doing this kind
of bias and variance trade off
so with this little word about
idea of random forest i go to the third
technique that i want to introduce you
to that is quantile regression forest
it is made up of two words
one type and regression sorry quantile
regression and forest
this is just another version of quantum
regression
or sorry
another version or other variant of
random forest so that is why forest word
is
incorporated from there
it just tweaked the way
regression problem is solved in the
random forest
where qrf method is for regression in
this method trees are grown as a
standard random forest algorithm
so until trees are grown there is no
change in the quantile regression forest
technique and random forest technique
once trees are created what happens is
see
in usual regression if you solve in the
with the random forest
it takes mean of all the nodes all the
tree outcomes came out
but in the quantile regression
it just creates or it just
obtained
instead of mean it obtains all the
values from all the trees
in a particular node
and it creates
repeat it creates
a distribution
distribution based on quantiles
this gives us
a tremendous advantage we use we solve
the quantile regression and we have a
distribution of our prediction outcome
and that is something different than the
random forest technique the raw random
forest technique
example i have given i have 50 trees
so in random forest i will get 50
predicted values and i will take the
mean of that but in quantal regression i
will create a distribution out of 50
predicted values from the 50 trees of my
random forest
when we get the distribution
we also get a confidence interval in the
quantile regression forest
and that is something
we want that is something we will use
quantile degradation forest is a
non-parametric method
and it is an accurate way much more
accurate way than using ols method or
ols kind of method for regression forest
and it can accommodate very high number
of predictor variables which is very
common case nowadays while solving
machine learning problems
nowadays if we are solving machine
learning problems
we get large number of variables our
input variables or predictor variables
and quantile regression forest handles
that thing extremely well so that is why
we are preferring contra regression
first over other techniques
uh
target variable again could be
heterostatistic
its variance can be changed and that is
how it is
uh now
i had taken three slides just to explain
the
basics of quantile regression forest
now i will jump to my example
my example is for credit cards
expenditure
and credit card expenditure is a
business
in which we want to know
the credit card spend by individual
users
this gives us a fairly good
understanding
of
how much will be spent on credit cards
and who will spend and who will spend
how much if we can predict accurately
and this gives us
enormous advantage in the business
so
uh
it is a data science problem
its prediction problem its
supervised learning problem
in this
and uh
usually
banks have millions of users
typically every person have multiple
credit cards
and there are multiple credit card users
available
which counts into millions and they
spend
they spend and pay back to their
respective financial institution like
banks or other institutions on monthly
basis
so each month a bill is generated for
every credit card user i am very sure
most of us will have credit card and
most of us will be paying to some bank
the credit bill
credit card bill each month
so our data input data is the
combination of
monthly expenditure of credit card user
now we all have credit limit
but
we spend differently because of our
behavior
so predicting the credit card
expenditure is actually predicting the
behavior of the credit card customers
few of us pay more you may
few of us spend more
most of us spend moderately
few of us spend drastically low and all
this information
need be obtained who's who is
extravagant spender who is the spender
who spends less
who is the spender
who is the user
who
will maintain his credit card
he will pay almost constant amount each
month and
what is that constant amount that helps
us a lot and he will pay the bill each
month
so
all this information helps to banks how
much money will be off take
in the credit cards
factor other thing is
most of the banks want to know how the
which are the variables or which are the
factors
driving the business of credit card
spring
and our tool should be in a position to
tell us what is driving what is
difference
between two two users
with the same with the same background
one spend a lot more than the other one
so what is driving the thing
because we we assume that both the users
are same but something else is happening
because of which one user spends lot
more than another user so this is again
as i said it's a behavioral problem
and we of course want to know the
variables which are driving the business
or factors which are driving the
business
now
to solve this problem we needed lot of
data
but we were not having much data
in fact we had no data at all
so what we did was we did some research
in the market
we saw all the statistics some plot some
reports
and we
vaguely determined what are the
factors determine the credit card
expenditure
uh so we taken all that
factors and simulated some data
we simulated something like 9000 records
of data
9000 man month or user month of credit
card bills were simulated in our data
and
the
factors we determined was
credit card limit
how much a person can is allowed to
spend gender
number of dependents an individual
credit card user has someone has four
four dependents someone has three
dependent someone has
two dependents on that
income income is in dollars
sorry dollar sign is missing here
this is 61 000 is annual income of
individual user it is not monthly income
this annual income
here we have assumed that income will
remain constant between months
and uh the data is for one year so but
for whole year the income will not
change it will remain constant this was
an assumption and we simulated the data
for average income of
a citizen
and
this is something like 68 1088 000 125
000 these are just the 10 lines of data
we have actually simulated 9000 lines of
data
other important factor we considered was
employment status again we assume that
employment status does not change whole
year
and people who are employed will remain
employed holier people who are
unemployed will remain unemployed
earlier
and
we have already determined one more
factor that was marital status
people who are married people who are
single there is substantial difference
between their buying pattern and their
expenditure pattern
so this
this was again this is again a simulated
column a simulated variable added to the
total data set
and there is age group
so
we learned from various reports that age
group is an important driving factor
with the credit card sprint
gen x spend lot more than jen said
and baby boomer spends differently than
millennials and
other people
so we we we actually
have these users or age group in the
same proportion
as they have they are in the
uh
natural data or the
actual population of of the people so if
gen x is 20 of total in actual
population also 20 people are genetics
people
but
end of the day it is simulated data
hence please do not try to
judge it with the real world knowledge
we all have about credit card spending
or the financial market of any country
this is all simulated data
it will not withheld withstand the rules
we have in the uh
we we have in the real world scenarios
there are eight variables i describe all
of all the eight variables and there are
total
9175 request used for expenditure
so with this setting done
what we have done is we created
uh
we created a few
not few in fact one quantile regression
forest using our
r tool
r is very famous and statistical tool we
all might be familiar with that
and
we divided our 9000 records into
80 for training
we did our design as 80 for training and
20 for
testing
and we predicted after creating the
model we predicted all the values we had
in the 20 percent of testing data set
and
first question anyone will ask is what
will be the median credit card
expenditure
and this is the result we obtained
median credit card expenses expenditure
of user will be according to this table
this table is having three columns so
quantile 0.1 quantile 0.5 0.5 quantile
is the median value
this is the in between the center most
value
of our
distribution obtained from the
regression forest
and quantiled to 90 value is the highest
value
other thing i would like to say is see
this is a cumulative distribution values
one five percentile include point one
percentile as well 0.9 percentile
includes both 0.1 and 0.5 percentile as
well
that's why all the time every time you
will find that
if you move from left to right
values are increasing
and they always increase this way
once we found this we all know the
distribution
or the range i should say the range of
expenditure of each and every user we
have how they will
spend in the coming month
and this is how it is
it is given that
given here in the result
this is 9th and 10th percentile
this 10 and
0.1 that is 10th percentile and 0.9 that
is 90 percentile in median
is something we have given for
prediction
we can predict between one percentile to
100 time 100 values as well
usually what people do is they predict
between
[Music]
five percentile and 97.5 percentile
values
usually people also
predict with the 25 percentile 50
percentile 75 percentile and 100
percentile as well
so
these values can be determined as per
our use case and our need i have taken
it as a usual case we take median 0.1
and 0.9 percentile
now we have predicted these values
first question anyone will ask is
how confident we are about this range
so what we did was
we took 20 records
we took 20
records and we took the actual
and
compared it with 10 50 and 90 percentage
out of 20 percentiles we have realized
that 2 out of 20 cases it has gone
beyond the range
you can see this this 12 number value
has gone beyond the range
and you can see that 16 number value has
gone beyond the range
we have yellow marked the values two
values which have gone beyond the range
so we can be
ninety percent sure
that our value predicted the actual
value
will be in the range we already
predicted
only 10 percent of time the value will
go beyond our range
and this this
result can be plotted in multiple ways
including box plot
including bar chart or anything we
plotted in in a line fashion and you can
see that the yellow line always remain
in between
a
gray line and the blue line
and it always always changes the the
orange line that is our median line
with that said what we are saying is
if we predict with a quantity regression
forest
most of the time our prediction will be
very close
to the median value
and very seldomly or very rarely they
will jump out of our 10 percentile and
90 percentile range
and this is how the prediction result
will look like and how we can say that
how confident we are we are 90 percent
confident at night we are confident that
90 percent of the time i should say
our values will fall into our range and
this is the biggest advantages result we
obtain for quantile regression forest
from this thing
now
as i said
as i said
we always want to know
we always want to know or we as a bank
we as a financial institution we as an
analyst always want to know
what drives the credit card expenditure
we took a random forest
right everywhere time random forest is
executed
a byproduct
by product why because primarily random
forest predicts the gives us the
reproduction
scores random forest as a by-product
also gives us the variable importance
plot
i mean variable importance plot is it
tells us which are the variables
which
are determining the results of playing
very key role in determining the result
and here the results we had drawn or we
have found is
like this is that
biggest factor that is determining the
result is income
people have higher income
higher running income
not the wealth wealth is very different
thing wealth is not considered in the
random forest
they spend the more and this is the most
important factor
so to predict what is most important is
income
followed by income is credit card limit
here we are assuming that credit card
limit will be 10 of income which is not
very correct in the real world scenario
why because in the real world each user
will have multiple credit cards and
while giving the credit cards bank
considers that how many more credit
cards you have or how much more credit
limit you have with other credit cards
so credit card limit also plays very
important role in in real world also and
in this scenario also in the similar
data this has shown that credit card
limit is the second most important
factor
third most important factor that came
out is number of dependents
number of dependents are a two-way
dexterous variable
it impacts both the way
if i have more number of dependents i
may spend more because of their needs
but considering i have more liability i
have to look after many more people i
may spend less on the
items which are discretionary hence the
number of dependents is another albeit
extras but very important variable in
determining the credit card sprint and
this is how other variables are also
listed
and random forest
gives us this results very well
how the results are given is it ranks
the importance of variables in
in regression and this is how it is
given
the outcome of it is determine the order
is
node purity
node purity is included node purity is
the thing random for is use
for determining the variable importance
the importance result can be changed
with other other matrix as well like
there is one more matrix is used for
error measures but we have used the node
purity which is general generally used
method to determine the
variable importance and this variable
importance is given here
more than that
thanks always interested to find out
if
who will spend more where are my
extravagant expanders spam strife people
spend rift users
given two users have same credit limit
hundred dollars one person will try to
spend more than hundred dollars in fact
total hundred dollars another person
will just spend thirty dollars
right if right even if rest of the
things are saying their background is
saying their income is same
one person is a spend thrift other
person is not a spreadsheet
and this is again a behavioral thing
many of us behaved all of us based
differently
so
uh
all of us based differently and banks
are always interested to find out these
kind of people
when they are the business they bring
business to the table because if they
spend more
bank hands more as a commission or as an
interest payment and same time they are
risk as well
because they spend a lot
giving them credit limit will spend a
lot they will spend a lot and they may
not be able to pay back the
uh
the debt
the debt
a credit card bill so this is a two-way
thing
and
we have drawn is something like
we take a 97 percentile prediction
that how much maximum they will
they will pay
maximum they will spend
and we had taken their actual spend
and we had taken the difference between
actual spend and predicted spend
divided by their credit card limit
so here actual minus credit rate by
credit card limit gives us some numbers
and we've taken five best
five out of nine thousand
highest spend thrift people
and one person has spent more than 14
percent
of it their
predicted value
and uh next person has paid 10 spend 10
percent more these are just the
simulated numbers
but
these are just the simulated numbers
but
they are extremely useful numbers
they tell us
a lot about the behavioral pattern of
individuals
not only the top five people bank may be
interested to know the
behavioral pattern of each and every
user
and
these are the results can be obtained by
content regression forest
the method to determine this is derived
by me but different methods can be
derived by seeing the data seeing the
matrix we have
and these percentage numbers can be
differently obtained or the same
same
outcome can be differently obtained by
different matrix as well
so with this the quick
with quick
presentation
i will open the floor for questions so
kindly tell us the questions
and we will discuss the
discuss discuss about your questions now
okay sunil we have a number of questions
from the audience we have
some that came in from our youtube live
stream as well
and
most of them are pretty technical so
sweta asks
if we have a highly positive correlation
between variables in the data set
and those columns are very important for
our prediction and we can't remove those
columns
how do we move forward with that data
set and how do we fit it to our machine
learning model
fine
see correlated variables
how one method in our regression models
are in the prediction modeling is
regularization
this phenomena is known as multi
multicollinearity and
random forest handles these correlated
variables well this is one of the reason
people use random forest because what
random forest does is
you may have few variables which are
poor in
linearly correlated to each other and
you cannot drop them but while creating
the trees random forest will take few of
them and will not take few of them and
random forests will take this decision
at random
okay
and this thing is
into the random forest and it takes care
of that otherwise jump to the quantile
regression technique
which is very similar to ols and apply
the regularization method that will also
solve the
problem okay
um
zina truman asks uh
can random forest be used for time
series prediction
and if so how
see
time series it is not actually time
series prediction but it is time series
forecasting
whether random forest can be used for
time series forecasting uh
i am not exposed to that
but for time series forecasting there
are other methods in machine learning
data science world which is known as
recurrent neural networks
content regression can also be solved by
deep learning method
but
all the methods are not included in that
but
time series thing is little off track to
the random forest it is off track to
prediction modeling and it more falls
into the sequential model basket that is
solved by recurrent neural network so i
would pref i would advise like let us
try to use
other techniques which are more
more prominent for time series
forecasting
all right
um
umash asks if you could go into a little
bit about the difference between
decision trees and neural networks
uh decision tree and neural network is
see decision tree
is something like
uh recursive partitioning division
method
here it is non-parametric method
while neural network is a parametric
method neural network is deep neural
network is having layers there are a lot
of weights and they use back propagation
to generate a prediction outcome
pointer regression can be solved by both
the decision trees or regression tree
and
deep neural networks both
uh there is there are a lot of
differences between both of them but
yeah point delegation what is the topic
of today can be solved by both
deep neural network using different loss
function
and with the regression forest as well
um clifford asks in hindsight
the analysis and the technique seem
logical
but it's rarely the case when you're
looking forward
so he's curious in your process what
attempts did you make which failed and
what how did you learn from those
failures
uh
i actually tried to this technique is
very good
and
it actually i tried this technique where
i failed with this technique is was with
a
stock market prediction
and i failed in the stock market
prediction which was very
just recently asked question was time
series kind of thing
why time series kind of thing does not
fit with this technique was
because i realized that there is very
basic assumption in prediction modeling
that is known as iid
independent and identically distributed
thing
what happens is if we are predicting the
credit card spend each credit card spend
is
independent of our previous credit
card's friend but in the time series or
in the
uh
these kind of things where i failed with
this technique was i realized that our
current
current data point is very much related
to previous data point today stock
market
data is very much related to yesterday's
stock market data
at these places this technique fails
other technique that place this
technique will not much help so less see
it needs some
some
statistical background to understand the
distribution
or this distribution is ecdf
empirical cumulative distribution
function and not discuss much in detail
because we had i had just 50 minutes but
to understand the outcome of this
technique we must have some background
in statistics and we must understand how
the distribution works so that is
another point i would like to add here
um
so we had a couple questions about
quantiles and if you could go into how
how
the quantile method differs from the
point
method and then
is there a criteria for choosing which
quantiles to compare for example when
you did your
10 50
90 quantiles
um
is
is there a
way to decide which quantiles to use for
a particular problem
uh i haven't
heard i read so many things i had in my
hand
but i never found like what quantize is
the best one
almost everyone uses 50th quantile on
median quantile
more than million content what it they
it always uses is
it uses something above the median
quantile and something below the median
contact
so 50 to 40 plus 90 and 40 minus that is
10 to 10 50 90 was my answer which
quantile to be used but there is no hard
and fast or no statistical rule i have
seen at least which says which tells us
which quantile to be used
and uh just a
quick if you could comment on this quick
question
what happens when you choose
quantile of 100
it is the maximum method it is the
maximum value you can choose it it is
the maximum value you can ever imagine
with the data given to you
okay
um
uh
sabashi's asked on what basis
do you select a sub sample from the main
sample
is there a particular logic or set of
rules behind the segmentation
it is actually not segmentation
it is bagging
bagging is means you you have a big
population sample
and from big population sample you keep
on taking small small samples
and
that is the way we take the sample at
least every random forest is having
inbuilt mechanism
how much data to be used in a sample
usually people take it as uh
they fixed number of samples like
hundreds a hundred records 500 records
but a large number of samples need to be
taken from the bigger sample what i've
shown in my
presentation is a big circle that is
population data and smaller circles
which is the thing otherwise there is no
rule like you cannot take 10 line sample
or you you should take at least 100
lines but there is no such rule in that
but this is
backing process as long as our sampling
process is as for the backing
principles defined we are correct we can
take the samples
um
vimal asks a question related to
preparing for a career in data science
what kind of math background
does somebody need
to prepare for a career in data science
or in ai and ml
is linear equations and
matrices and determinants
enough to know or what other areas
will they need to uh get a background in
okay
this is little
subjective understanding of the things
i believe that four branches of
mathematics are required to be learned
one is linear algebra and matrix
correctly included
probability and distributions
uh
these two are needed
uh then
then comes the vectors
how data vectors are there which are
used in the something like principal
component analysis online the basis of
vector the angle between vectors and all
that and fourth is little of calculus
if you would being a data scientist you
want to understand how optimization
method works so we must know little
about the calculus
how what is a gradient what is
limit what is gradient
all these things
so these four things are there which in
the mathematics are needed to be learned
to
learn the basic of data science now
again there is a subjective answer this
is little you may find it little weak
but
how much of probability need be known
this is something subjective i believe
we should know
certain basic distribution and
probability certain basics
calculus methods
certain basics matrices of course
variant
sorry
inverse and
similar things need to be known so the
with these four four branches and the
minimum knowledge of four non branches
high school level knowledge of these
four branches will will be enough to
learn the cracks of the
data science and machine learning
thank you for that um
i'm gonna ask a question about
visualization and
what type of
plots or
you would use to identify outliers
and also
non-visualization question
would it be a good practice to discard
outliers or do they provide
valuable
information see
[Music]
outliers are
the not always to be discarded
in many cases outliers are the real data
we are looking for the real outcome we
are looking for
like in my last slide what i discussed
is something like a
outlier method
find out who are the people who are
extravagant spenders they actually break
the distribution and their value is
beyond the distribution they spend more
than 97 percentile of the value
so authorized not be discarded how to
determine outliers
see in the random forest there is one
very special kind of forest known as
isolation forest
similarly if you see that
there are various methods one class
classification method one class svm one
class so many methods which are used for
outright detection
here
just by seeing the distribution you can
determine whatever point is lying away
from the distribution that is the point
is the outlier
now comes to outlier visualization
usually people use box plot to visualize
the outlier
in that case what happens is whatever
falls behind second
and third quartile between 25 percentile
and
is vaguely considered an outlier
or
in that range many things are outlier
again definitions are the the values are
25 and 75 are little subjective
but whatever found outside the box is an
outlier is
is a visualization used
other visualizations that can be used
various methods have different
visualization one we cannot say that
which will be the best suited here
okay
um
we have more questions than we have
actual time for but i will get to a few
more if you can
stay with us uh
sunil um
we had a couple questions regarding
preparation for a career in ai and
machine learning
um
one of them is uh
what type of experience and how long
does somebody need
uh if they're new in the it field in
order to become employable in
uh as an ai engineer ai practitioner
[Music]
i had a lot of experience but not much i
have
i cannot answer this because
uh it's related subjective how much how
fast you can pick up how fast you can
learn the things and all that
but
[Music]
it's little difficult to say
but
see
start with
data science then jump to machine
learning
and they then try to learn many things
which are there in ai but which is not a
machine learning
and
data science machine learning
is again divided into two parts the
thing which is one is machine learning
one is deep learning so deep learning
will be little difficult to catch up
machine learning is rather easy provided
we have some statistical and mathematics
background
so
this thing will do the job
i am not sure how many years but this
should do the job
this is
this should do
this this will help
we have i just put into the chat uh link
to one of our programs one of the simply
learn programs in ai and machine
learning
and if you go to that page you can also
browse through and see other programs in
the same category depending on what it
is you want to learn and how far you
want to go
and those are are
things that build upon you know your
foundations that
sunil mentioned about the the different
branches of math that you
need to understand and some of the
programs include that training in math
some are based on the idea that you
already have it
um
uh
we have a question about
a
and
so scott phil
asks
what is the difference between
ols ordinarily square method and aln and
his
bias is that ols
he feels is suitable for machine
learning aln
for more traditional statistic methods
so first off can you
tell us what aln is
does that bring a bell
elm even i am not exposed to alm
but
ordinary least square is something which
predicts the
point prediction the conditional mean as
i explained in my slide
point of equation is something that
brings us the range of that uh
range of that
okay
um
yeah i'm not
sure what
he meant and
what uh he meant by aln so i
apologize for that
um
and
let's see
cassie asked a quick
question about the model or
when you look at node purity how are you
measuring that
[Music]
what is node
uh no when when when you're giving a
measure of node purity
and you're looking at the pure node
purity uh what
how is that measured
okay this is little big process
while creating the trees
which are the nodes which are the
variables were used in this
used in the
spreading the decision tree variables
this is how the node purity is measured
like how many times it has used and how
many times it has given the good
prediction that is i know purity is
immediate but it is really big process
if you just search this is a little big
process to be explained in
so fast but basically my answer will be
how a particular variable is is used to
determine the split inside decision tree
or individual decision trees it actually
counts how many times that particular
variable is used and that is how node
purity comes out in the picture
okay and so the units in that column of
our
number of times it's used
yes
okay
that was the basic question and
let me see what else we have
um
can you comment aditya has a question on
the process of training ai for
simulation of tasks
is that something within your
experience
oh okay
yeah
this is a different seems to be a
different
subject
um
what is overfitting and underfitting
asks rob
overfit underfitting is when you're
under
under doing the work of fitting the data
example underfitting example is you want
to predict if some person will die from
heart attack or not
and what you do is you just take the
weight as input variable so when you
have very less number of variables you
cannot learn the actual
data actual causality and that is under
fitting
this is something like killing a lion
with a small knife your knife is really
not correct you are your unused data or
your
you are not use your data properly you
not use your
your information properly
overfitting is exactly opposite
over fitting is you use all the
variables and you really come out with a
weekly pattern
wiggly pattern which fits well in the
training data
and not fit well in the testing data
that is over fitting
so
again under fitting means
using very less number of variables and
making a model which is too simplistic
and over fitting means using everything
you have and come out with a very
complex model which does not work in the
real world
which does not generalize well in
statistics terms or machine learning
terms which does not generalize well
which memorize more so that is called
over fitting so this is
under fitting stands for bias over
fitting stands for variance and random
force does a trade-off between bias and
variance so there are various methods to
take care of under fitting and
overfitting
and random forest is having inbuilt
method to do uh handle under fitting and
overfitting in that case
okay
and there's a related question um
from sadir
uh who asks about random forest and the
trees keep splitting down in the
hierarchy level
uh is there a point at which that could
result in overfitting
see overgrown tree overfits data
techniques use data strum which is just
one level of tree
but what happens is
over fitting get handled out because
there are a lot of trees
and
the overfitting results in variants
you have lot of trees lot of variants
but whereas can get average out and get
reduced
so
bigger tree creates overfitting yes
thus
individual trees in random forest crates
over fitting yes
but random forest overall results which
comes with the averaging of everything
reduce the variance that is the way
random forest
helps excellent
um i think we'll take one last question
here from the list uh because we're over
time
but ahmad asks um
you displayed in the presentation the
10th percentile 50th percentile 90th
percentile
um
when you mentioned the highest
97th percentile would you
would you uh elaborate on
how that relates or what applications
you would use that in
see for different slides we run the
model differently we done prediction
differently
10 and 50 and 90 was the first first
slide
and 97 was used just to predict the over
the extravagant spenders
so it is not that that we always use 10
50 and 90.
we have used 97.5 also we experimented
with 100 percentile also so
everything we had done
okay and
basically what you're saying is that
depending on your application if you're
trying to find a
confidence interval
that your median is going to fall into
you might choose
different high and low values and then
higher and lower percentiles if you're
looking for an outlier you for example
you might look for
the
high percentile or a very low percentile
in order to see
where
values fall outside of the the
expected range
yes yes
wonderful um
so
sunil um i think that's all the time we
have for questions i'm going to go back
to
um
my screen and
i will
share the closing slides
um
so
we will do a quick poll
toward the end here and i apologize to
everyone whose questions we could not
get to
due to time constraints
but um
we will do this poll here
and again my apologies for not being
able to get to all the questions
um but
these were excellent questions that
were very
insightful into the into the material
so very glad to have a an audience with
this level of
interest and perception in this material
and so this quick poll is about what you
would like to learn and add to your
toolkit if you had the chance
whether you're at the start of your
career or
trying to move it up to the next level
and
when you would like to start doing that
and
here are the results of the poll
and
not surprisingly
folks in this audience are most
interested in data science ai and
machine learning
and
it's good to see that
about a third of you would like to start
doing that right away so
as i mentioned in the chat we do have
programs in ai and machine learning we
also have other programs that you can
see on our website
data science and all these other
disciplines that are on the on the poll
here
and
invite you
to check those out
meanwhile i will
thank sunil very profusely for being
here today and sharing
with us his expertise
um
showing us a
example of
an actual machine learning
model and technique so that you get a
feel for
you know what are some of the new things
coming up in the field and how it
applies and how it can be used in the
real world
um here is his linkedin
information so you'll be able to connect
with him i'll drop that into the chat in
a moment
but um thank you again sunil
thank you thank you stuart thank you
okay and
with that um i just want to mention our
next simply learn webinar
which is
uh
coming up in two days
and it is in cloud computing and
devops and these are
important
new fields for um
technology they're very
quick growing
their transforming
how software is developed and tested and
delivered
and
dropping a link
to this
our speaker will be a digital leader
from accenture matthew david
and
as i promised here is also
sunil's
linkedin information so you can
connect with him
we will be sending out an email tomorrow
with a link to this uh
presentation
uh the webinar
we can't share the powerpoint of the
slides
but you will be able to see that through
the recording of the webinar and we
invite you all to connect with us
and keep track of us
uh at simplylearn on facebook
on twitter on linkedin
and we hope to see you both at future
simply learn webinars and also
to have you join our
simply learn learning community
so thank you all very much for being
here
and
we appreciate it this concludes our
webinar today
you